this debt ceiling deal did get passed
and housed a majority leader Kevin
McCarthy seems pretty pleased with
himself here we go
after America first
more than two-thirds of our conference
voted for it
we got all the Democrats who signed a
discharge petition to say they would
never raise the debt ceiling only raise
it clean
we got them to vote for it too so think
about how much further we can go
told you then it's not how you start
it's how you finish
each week we have stood up for the
American public
be it its strongest border security we
put the citizens of America first
and we didn't do it by taking the easy
way we didn't do it by the ways that
people did in the past by just lifting
it we decided that you had to spend less
and we achieved that goal
all right before we all jump into that
let's go to another Republican who did
not vote for it Texas Congressman chip
Roy hi colleagues be very clear not one
Republican should vote for this deal it
is a bad deal
no one sent us here
to borrow an additional four trillion
dollars
to get absolutely
nothing in return but at best if I'm
being really generous
a spending freeze for a couple of years
that's it
that's about what you get
and frankly you're going to make things
worse in my Democratic colleagues know
it
that's why they're supporting it that's
why they're going around gleeful look
there's a reason our Democrat colleagues
support this there's a reason that Mitt
Romney supports this
there's a reason that bill Crystal
supports this
it's all the same stuff
Kyle it strikes me that they're both
telling the truth to a degree McCarthy's
like hey the Democrats wanted some
really crazy crap they didn't get all
that and then Chip's like no it's still
uh you know low to turd basically
well I'm just I'm just tired of the
gaslighting it just reminds me of like
you're on a tight budget and your wife
goes out shopping and she uses the
credit card that is almost maxed out to
buy you know a dress for 200 and she
comes back and tells you well it wasn't
300 I saved us a hundred dollars no it
you know it's not like we're making
money off of this you're spending uh
money that we don't have on things that
we don't need which is really the
concern of a lot of taxpayers so the
federal budget the funny the interesting
thing about all of this is that you look
at the IRS I think that's a great one
the IRS Staffing so they were able to
cut a a little bit of the budget like 10
like it was like 12 percent of that yeah
it's a proposed budget but the
interesting thing about that is if you
look at the Biden administration's
Arguments for this hiring more agents
over the course of 10 years they want to
recoup 200 billion dollars or so from
the richest people in order to pay for
the climate scan for carbon energy
credits and you know uh green
initiatives and so on my heart and my
brain are with chip like this is just
more nonsense we know nothing is going
to be resolved or get better or anything
and then the purely the part of me that
just understands politics is like well
McCarthy if he doesn't do a deal
basically we know the Republicans get
blamed for it and likely we do end up in
a recession and most of us don't want to
end up in a recession is this just kind
of why politics both sucks and blows
yes it is it is why politics sucks and
blows um but also you have to remember
that 46 Progressive Democrats also voted
against this bill and claimed that you
know Biden had given up too much